pretty little liars kept fans guessing
for seven sinister seasons this show
seemed to have everything mystery murder
and manipulative hotties we were able to
unearth some pretty delicious secrets
about this popular TV show that might
shock you stay tuned to the end to
discover the truth about the spin-off
that was just exposed if you're new here
make sure to subscribe to the things for
new videos about your favorite shows and
now here are 10 dark secrets in Pretty
Little Liars
orange is the new pretty with the cast
of Pretty Little Liars there was plenty
of drama off screen as well as on but
even celebrities are not above the law
Brandon Jones knows that all too well
according to people crime the actor who
plays the creeptastic character Andrew
Campbell got in a bit of trouble with
authorities because of an incident that
happened with a neighbor in October of
2015 apparently he got in an argument
with his neighbor and showed him that he
was carrying a concealed gun and that's
not the only time in March of 2016 in a
heated exchange Brandon pulled out a
knife and pointed a gun at his neighbor
we know his character andrew has been a
suspect with the police in the show this
seems like a case of life imitating art
we're guessing his neighbors are
probably going to steer clear of this
guy in the future Brandon was charged
with a felony count of assault and two
counts of exhibiting a deadly weapon and
exhibiting a concealed firearm in public
he was sentenced to 180 days in jail in
ordered to do community service
considering he could have been on the
hook for up to five years it seems the
judge went easy on him maybe it was a
fan of the show a 12 year old liar
apparently Sasha Pieterse did a little
lying of her own in order to land the
role of Alison DiLaurentis on the show
Sasha's character in this show was
supposed to be at least a freshman in
high school
but in reality sasha was only 12 years
old when she got the part we watched her
audition tape and it was definitely
mature for her age
not surprising that she landed the role
it has been hinted at in interviews that
Sasha had told a little white lie about
her age in order to land the role
according to Cosmo the head honchos on
Pretty Little Liars didn't realize how
young she was until after she had
already shot the pilot
total Alison move with seven seasons
under her belt we'd say she definitely
grew into the part betty would never
have guessed that she was so young when
she started the show her oldest co-star
was Tyler Blackburn who played the role
of Caleb rivers this babyface was 28
years old when he played the role of a
guy who was supposed to be 10 years
younger
that's a 16 year age difference between
Sasha and Tyler we would never have
guessed the magic of the small screen is
pretty amazing so over it in an
interview with People Entertainment
Weekly Shane Mitchell said that she
thought they were ending the show at the
most perfect time she shared that she
believes there couldn't have been a
better ending for Pretty Little Liars
after she explained that they shot 26
episodes in one year it's clear that she
may have been a little burnt out in the
interview she turned to showrunner
Marlene King and said she thought they
wrapped it up perfectly she expressed
that it was hard to keep a mystery going
for that long enough every episode keep
the fans engaged and wanting more she
took no time to shed tears at the ending
of the show according to the LA Times
after the show ended she finished work
on the horror film cadaver is ready to
follow up to her book bliss and has her
own reality show on full screen called
shades of Shaye when she started talking
about vacation spots we concluded that
this hard-working girl is ready for some
rest and relaxation and who can blame
her she has certainly earned it so where
are her favorite vacation spots she said
it was a toss-up between Morocco and
Italy she hopes to live in Italy one day
that casts health struggles Sasha has
been very open about her struggle with
polycystic ovary syndrome or PCOS which
caused her to gain 70 pounds in two
years PCOS is no joke it's an underlying
issue created by an imbalance of
hormones in the body and causes small
cysts on the ovaries Sasha went on
Dancing with the Stars as a way to take
charge of the weight gain that was
caused by a hormone imbalance in her
body brought on by PCOS way to go Sasha
other cast members have dealt with
health issues too in 2014
Troian Bellisario went public about her
eating disorder she told a online that
her quest for perfection let her down a
dangerous self-destructive path her
friends intervened and she got help as
part of Troy's recovery she wrote and
starred in the film
which shows the struggles of a young
woman dealing with an eating disorder
overall she emerged triumphant trans
castmate lucy hale came out in support
of Tryon and admitted to battling with
an eating disorder as well in the
September issue of Cosmopolitan she
revealed that she would go days without
eating through it all these young women
supported each other
proving you can overcome anything with a
little help from your friends hiding the
bun in the oven
Taman Circo can play Jenna in PLL was
pregnant during the filming of season 4
she announced her pregnancy on Instagram
with a picture of the positive test in
the caption she wrote and then and this
happened she followed up that post with
a picture of her and her loving husband
celebrating her new baby bump she
reassured her fans with the caption
don't worry still shooting PLL I
wouldn't let you down Taman kept her
promise and shot the rest of the fourth
season working with the crew to hide her
bun in the oven
they used clever angles big bags and
loose-fitting clothing to conceal the
pregnancy it just didn't work with the
storyline for Jenna to be pregnant while
taman is a great book most people agree
that jenna would probably not have been
up to the challenge
Taman went on to create a mommy and
lifestyle blog called bottle and heels
she wanted to bring women together to
talk about their struggles and victories
of motherhood as well as discuss travel
beauty and fashion given Tammuz
experience as a working mother her blog
posts are full of insight honesty and
poetic musings about being a modern mom
in today's world she truly is doing it
all and looking amazing while doing it
as Rhea is you okay can we talk about
how inappropriate battle Ezra and Aria
aka Ezria relationship was pretty little
liars creators expected fans to root for
this illegal relationship without
raising some important questions about
certain laws that prevent minors from
dating older men to the first episode of
PLL 24 year old Ezra meets
sixteen-year-old Aria in a bar and they
hook up in the bathroom later Aria
discovers the Ezra is actually her
English teacher awkward since he met
Aria in a bar we all believed he didn't
know she was so young and therefore
committed a forgivable offense
Jilla was revealed in season 4 that Ezra
knew who aria was the whole time and
therefore knew how old she was when he
got busy with her so it's okay to
exploit a young girl as long as you are
researching her friend's death so you
can write a book we don't think so and
since the show's creators wanted fans to
believe Ezra and Aria were a pair of
star-crossed lovers it seems they
celebrate illegal activities with miters
they got some major backlash for this
from viewers so they tried to add a
police report at a later episode to
address
Ezra's predatory behavior Photoshop fail
photoshopping actresses and models is
nothing new in Hollywood many actresses
have spoken out against overly
photoshopped photos of themselves the
[ __ ] girls unreasonable expectations and
standards of beauty Ashley Benson who
played the role of Hannah on the show is
one of the actresses speaking out
against this deception in Tinseltown in
an interview with People magazine she
revealed that she was miffed about how
photoshopped she and her cast mates were
in promotional photos of Pretty Little
Liars she said nobody looked like
themselves she shared her frustrations
saying that even for magazine covers
they would Photoshop out imperfections
make her chest bigger her waist four
sizes smaller and made it so she didn't
even recognize herself she said she
never knew what to expect because she
had no control over the photo editing
process now she insists that
photographers not Photoshop photos aside
for minor touch-ups she sent out a
message to her young female fans not to
get down on themselves
she said that unless they announce that
a photo is not photoshopped it's
definitely photoshopped
she also reminded everyone that it takes
a lot of good lighting and makeup to
look like that the truth is no one looks
like that in real life
the transphobic plot twist after much
enticing mystery and anticipation PLL
finally delivered the big a reveal in
season six everyone was on the edge of
their seats but nearly filled to the
floor when the show dropped the
transgender bombshell who was his
character they revealed who had
tormented the liars during the course of
the story none other than the [ __ ]
characters CC which is short for
Charlotte Drake who was born as a boy
named Charles the trans community didn't
take too kindly to this as they believe
it contributes to a narrative in the
media that all trans people are
psychotic killers according to a
feminist online magazine this trope
appears in films like psycho and Silence
of the Lambs and TV shows like Law &
Order SVU and CSI this does little to
create understanding and tolerance for
the trans community fans were less than
enthusiastic about this plot twist
showrunner Marlene King defended the
choice to make the murderer trans by
saying she didn't want people to think
that this person was a villain because
of their gender identity
she said Stacy was a villain because she
came from a very crazy family and was
therefore genetically predisposed to
insanity she expressed that it was not
her intent to go backwards for the trans
community she wanted to go forward fans
hated the ending Pretty Little Liars had
a loyal fan following for seven seasons
but they had to deal with some angry
backlash after the final episode reveal
the series finale solved the mystery by
exposing the mastermind behind all the
pretty girl head games as Spencer's
super psycho British twin sister Alex
Drake and she is of course wearing the
same exact outfit as Spencer making for
the cliched conundrum which twin do I
shoot and then there's Jenna on a horse
fans were less than pleased these peeved
pretty fans took to Twitter to unleash
their discontent saying things like so
it took them and us seven years figuring
out who ad was and a horse and Jenna
Marshall can do it in seconds and that
they spent years watching PLL only to be
given an evil twin with a bad accent and
a horse that's a better detective than
all of them they also cited the horse as
the smartest character and Pretty Little
Liars tough crowd
then there were the fans that had a lot
of unanswered questions such as why Mia
was mentioned or how did Alex kill Wren
and how did the moms escape the overall
consensus is that fans lost seven years
of their lives invested in the show and
they want that time back Pretty Little
Liars spinoff
you probably know that Marlene King is
adapting the book series the
perfectionists to a new TV show on
freeform here are some intriguing
secrets we uncovered so far we know that
Sasha Pieterse and Janel Parrish will
return as their PLL characters Alison
DiLaurentis and mode a Vander Waal but
they will be in a new town with new
mysteries and a brand new murder so are
there any of the other characters from
Pretty Little Liars going to make an
appearance Sasha let it slip then it
won't be a problem at all to get Shay
Mitchell on the show
it's unclear how big her role will be
however don't get your hopes up that you
will see the return of all your favorite
PLL characters Lucy Hale revealed that
she doesn't think she will be in the
spinoff she said since its filming in
Vancouver she might go and stop the set
of it showrunner Marlene King shared
that she plans to deviate from the book
in a few ways she revealed plans to
focus more on the male characters
Marlene also revealed that not all four
of the main characters will survive the
first episode is the first victim going
to be a guy what do you think somebody
get the popcorn and that's it for ten
dark secrets in Pretty Little Liars
thanks for watching the things see you
next time
[Music]